In this final segment of
the lecture, I will briefly
juxtapose the US fair use doctrine
with a few strategies adopted
outside the United States.
Which of the available strategies makes
most sense is currently hotly debated.
Many countries, for example, the
United Kingdom, Japan, and Australia
are currently reviewing
their laws in this area.
So the legal landscape may shift soon.
In the meantime, you can and should
form your own opinions concerning
which of the approaches
I'll describe is optimal.
A few countries other
than the United States
have adopted general exceptions
to the rights of copyright owners
that resemble the fair use
doctrine in the United States.
The Copyright Law of
Israel, for example,
now contains a provision the closely
echoes section 107 of the US statute.
As you can see, it adopts the
same ad hoc open-ended approach
as is used in the US, and indeed employs
more or less the same four factors.
The Israeli provision does
however deviate from the US
approach in two respects.
First, as you can see,
it omits any reference
to the commercial character
of the defendant's use,
tacitly following the lead of the
US courts that in recent years
have, as we've seen, increasingly
demoted the commercial use sub factor.
Second, the final section
of the Israeli provision
empowers the Minister of Justice to
quote "make regulations prescribing
conditions under which a use shall
be deemed a fair use" close quote.
Thus far, apparently,
the Israeli government
has not exercised this power, but
it offers an intriguing possible way
in which the unpredictability
of fair use might be mitigated.
The copyright law of Singapore contains
a similar position, factors A, B, C
and D, once again echo, as you
can see the components of fair use
in the United States,
but factor E is new.
The instruction to consider
quote, "the possibility
of obtaining the work or
adaptation within a reasonable time
at an ordinary commercial
price," close quote,
presumably will have the effect of
limiting the availability of fair use
somewhat, because it would
weaken the position of defendants
who could have obtained a license from
the plaintiff but refused to do so.
This provision might also put
pressure on copyright owners
to collaborate in the
organization of a system,
like the Copyright Clearance
Center in the United States,
designed to facilitate licensing.
The net effect would be roughly
analogous to a compulsory licensing
system of the sort we have previously
considered in this series of lectures.
A recent study by Roya
Ghafele and Benjamin Gilbert
of the impact of the adoption of this
approach on the economy of Singapore
is broadly encouraging.
As we can see, these three variants of
fair use in the United States, Israel,
and Singapore are not identical,
but they share a basic approach.
Give judges considerable power to decide
after considering various factors,
whether a given putatively infringing
activity should be privileged.
Radically different is the so-called
"enumerated exceptions approach."
The central principle of the
strategy is that instead,
conferring on court's responsibility
to assess on an ad hoc basis defendants
assertions that they should
be excused for making
unauthorized uses of copyrighted
works, the legislature
should anticipate and provide
in advance for all circumstances
in which unauthorized
uses should be permitted.
This approach has been adopted in a much
larger set of countries than fair use.
It reigns in the European
Union, for example.
As you can see, article five of the
EU's Information Society Directive
employs this approach.
It identifies one exception
that member countries must adopt
and a long list of
exceptions, specifically
to the right of
reproduction and the right
to communicate or make works
available to the public, that
member countries may adopt.
The list is exhaustive, meaning
member countries are not
obliged to recognize all of them,
but they may adopt a subset,
but they may not recognize
more and they may not
adopt open-ended discretionary standards
like the US or Israeli approaches.
Many of the activities
that, as we've seen,
escape liability in the United
States on fair use grounds
are dealt with in specific
provisions in the EU's list.
For example, parody here in
item 3-K, but other things
such as copying student essays verbatim
for the purpose of running a plagiarism
detection service that have
been able to pass muster
under fair use in the
United States are likely too
new or idiosyncratic to have
been anticipated in 2001 and thus
would be hard to justify
under the EU's approach.
China as you can see, adopts
the same general strategy.
Article 22 of China's copyright
law contains a long list
of enumerated exceptions,
although shorter than the EU list.
Some items are not surprising.
For example, the ninth
exception for quote,
"gratuitous live performances of a
published work for which no fees are
charged to the public, nor
payments are made to performers,"
echos a provision of the US statute.
But others are more striking, for
example, the 10th exception which
privileges copying,
drawing, photographing,
or video recording of a work
of art put up or displayed
in an outdoor public space.
That provision is, at least
on its face, much broader
than any analogous exception in
either the United States or the EU.
Also remarkably expansive,
is the privilege
to translate quote, "a published work
of a Chinese citizen or legal entity
from Han language into minority
nationally languages for publication
and distribution in the country."
In sum, there are two polar
positions, the open-ended fair use
approach pursued in the United States,
and the enumerated exceptions approach
pursued in the EU, China,
and several other nations.
In between these two
sets of countries is
another set that have adopted what
might be described as hybrid models.
Typically, such hybrid systems
require a defendant first
to show that his behavior
falls into one on the list
of enumerated potential exceptions.
These tend to be more general than
the type of specific exceptions found
in the enumerated approach.
But a defendant who is able to fit
his activity into one of these boxes
is still not home free, he must
demonstrate that his conduct is also
justified on the basis
of a list of factors
that are analogous to those
employed in the United States.
An extra element sometimes
found in such hybrid systems
is a requirement that
the defendant acknowledge
that he is taking material from
the plaintiff, in other words,
he give credit where credit is due.
The result is to import into
the fair dealing analysis
a bit of the right of attribution
that as we've seen more commonly
is treated as a form of moral right.
The United States, as yet,
has no such requirement
and many defendants, who have given
the plaintiffs no credit whatsoever,
have successfully invoked the fair
use defense in the United States.
One of the many possible
implications of the cultural theory
we'll take up next week
is a reconsideration
of the US position on this point.
In other words, the possibility
of according greater recognition
to the principle of attribution
here in the fair use setting
or in other settings.
So where is this hybrid approach found?
The United Kingdom, as
you can see currently
employs such a system, although it may
make some dramatic changes to its law
soon.
Canada's does as well,
although it too is considering
further liberalization of its approach.
Australia, New Zealand, and
Taiwan have analogous setups.
So we turn to the general question.
Which of these strategies is best?
This issue is often
addressed as if it were
purely a question of optimal legal form.
So conceived the question of
the optimal fair use approach
is a variant of an age old
debate in legal theory.
Fair use, the US system, is an example
of a type of legal norm commonly known
as a "standard."
While the enumerated exceptions
approach is an example
of a type of legal norm known,
somewhat confusingly, as a "rule."
A standard, within this
literature, is a norm
that makes direct reference
to policy objectives.
For example, the best interests
of the child in family law,
or the avoidance of unjust
enrichment in contract law.
And then leaves judges
or other officials
lots of discretion in deciding
how best to accomplish
those ends when resolving
particular disputes.
A rule, by contrast,
constraints discretion.
It requires judges or other officials
to respond in a determinant way
to specific sets of readily
ascertainable variables.
So for example, a norm that
declared that only wise persons are
eligible to be president
of the United States
would be a standard, because it would
require judges or other decision
makers to make judgments
concerning whether candidates
are, all things considered, wise.
By contrast a norm that declared,
as it does in the United States,
that only persons over the
age of 35 may be president
is a rule because it leaves decision
makers very little discretion.
Standards and rules,
it is widely believed,
have characteristic
advantages and disadvantages.
For examples, standards are more
flexible, but also more unpredictable.
Rules are more predictable, and less
conducive to corruption or bias,
but they are also inevitably both
under-inclusive and over-inclusive.
In other words, they will fail to
advance policy goals as precisely
as well administered standards.
So which of the two
types of norm is better?
The standard answer is
that it varies by context.
Much of the current debate
about what to do about fair use
uses this same framework.
Should we have more ruleness?
I.e.
Move closer to the EU
enumerated approach.
Or should we have more standardness?
I.e.
Move closer to the US fair use approach.
Scholars who argue about
the issue in these terms
draw on many of the
considerations that figure
in the more general
rule-standards debate.
But framing the issue in these terms
misses two dimensions of the problem.
First, the enumerated exceptions
approach exemplified by the EU
is less rule-like than it might appear.
As Bernt Hugenholtz
and Martin Senftleben
have shown in a recent paper,
the information society directive
that we examined a few minutes
ago permits more discretion
than it might seem.
Not only do countries
enjoy latitude when
incorporating elements of
this list into their own laws,
but they can and sometimes do
formulate their national laws
in ways that confer on judges
some degree of discretion.
For example, the Swedish Copyright
Act, as Hugenholtz points out,
interprets provision 53D to permit
the quotation of published works quote,
"in accordance with proper usage and to
the extent necessary for the purpose,"
close quote.
That construction intentionally gives
judges a fair amount of latitude
when deciding whether a particular
defendant has gone too far.
Similarly, the Canadian courts
have stretched the categories
of their fair dealing system
considerably with the result
it operates in practice, more
like US fair use than it appears.
In short, characterizing the
choice among these systems
as a choice between rules and
standards is to some degree inaccurate.
Second, and more fundamentally,
on reflection the US system
is not so clearly a standard.
A standard you'll recall,
identifies a policy goal
and then gives judges
discretion in advancing it.
That's not really what the fair use
doctrine in the United States does.
Rather, it identifies some factors that
judges should consider, but doesn't
tell the judges why
those factors matter.
The law does not, in
other words, identify
the substantive goal of
the system as a whole.
The result is that judges
in the United States
are forced to decide for themselves
what copyright law should
be trying to achieve.
Maximize social welfare, reward authors
fairly, protect person-hood interests--
as we've seen all of those
are possible aspirations
for copyright law, which one
is your primary concern will
make a big difference in
how the statutory fair use
factors are construed and applied.
Judges in the United
States disagree concerning
fundamental purposes of copyright.
It should thus not be
surprising that as a result
they disagree concerning how fair
use should be construed and applied.
Seen this way, the current fair
use doctrine in the United States
is worse than a standard,
because it does not clearly
articulate a normative criterion--
a goal, or set of goals-- the judges
when deciding individual cases,
should strive to promote.
We ought to be able to
do better than that.
One possible route to a better regime
will be considered in the next lecture.